RAYMOND ARROYO BRINGS US AN
UPDATE IN "SEEN AND UNSEEN."
BOOK FIRST, THE TEMPTING OF AOC.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE"."
NOW, SHORTLY AFTER SHE STUNNED
HOUSE DEMOCRATS BY BEATING
LONGTIME INCUMBENT QUEENS
CONGRESSMAN JOE CROWLEY TWO
YEARS AGO,
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ WAS
BEING WRITTEN OFF BY MANY
REPUBLICANS AS JUST A FLASH IN
THE PAN.
JUST A FAR LEFT PROGRESSIVE WHO
CAUGHT AN OLD ESTABLISHMENT
DEMOCRAT OFF GUARD.
BUT I SAW THINGS DIFFERENTLY.
I THINK IT’S A MISTAKE FOR
CONSERVATIVES NOT TO TAKE HER
SERIOUSLY, TO BRUSH HER OFF AS A
FLASH IN THE PAN OR AN UPSTART.
SHE IS AS CLOSE TO A THOUGHT
LEADER THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS
TODAY, AND SHE HAS A MASSIVE
SOCIAL MEDIA FOLLOWING.
SHE HAS BOTH CHARISMATIC AND
SHE’S COMMITTED TO TRANSFORMING
BOTH OUR ECONOMIC SYSTEM AND OUR
CULTURE.
AND WHILE HER CANDIDATE,
BERNIE SANDERS, DIDN’T WIN THE
2020 NOMINATION,
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ HAS HAD
ENORMOUS INFLUENCE ON HER PARTY.
AS A FRESHMAN DEMOCRAT, HER
COALITION HELPED PULL JOE BIDEN
AND HER COLLEAGUES TO THE LEFT
ON KEY ISSUES, SUCH AS THE GREEN
NEW DEAL, HEALTH CARE, AND
IMPEACHMENT.
DEMOCRATS WILL DO ALMOST
ANYTHING, I’LL BE AT GRUDGINGLY,
TO AVOID BEING PRIMARIED BY HER
OR ONE OF HER CHOICES.
SHE PRESENTED HERSELF AS A
STRONG VOICE FOR WORKING-CLASS
AMERICANS, AND A STRONG CRITIC
OF MULTINATIONAL CORPORATIONS.
>> I’M PROUD TO BE A BARTENDER.
AIN’T NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT.
THERE’S NOTHING WRONG WITH
WORKING RETAIL, FOLDING CLOTHES
FOR OTHER PEOPLE TO BUY.
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH
BEING A WORKING PERSON IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND THERE IS EVERYTHING
DIGNIFIED ABOUT IT.
SPEAK OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE CHAMPION OF
THE WORKING CLASS.
>> Laura: I AGREE.
BUT WITH JOE BIDEN WAITING IN
THE WINGS POISED TO ANNOUNCE
MAJOR CHANGES TO U.S. TRADE AND
FOREIGN POLICY, AOC FACES SOME
DIFFICULT CHOICES.
HOW CAN SHE, WHO HAS ALWAYS
CLAIMED TO BE A CRUCIATE OR FOR
THE WORKING CLASS, YOU JUST
ca A WORLD
WHERE THE RICH ARE PUT FIRST AND
WORKING PEOPLE ARE PUT LAST IN
WASHINGTON, DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
>> Laura: WELL, GIVEN WHAT
BIDEN’S TEAM IS ALREADY TELLING
REMEMBER, BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC, BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS,
MIDDLE INCOME, AND ENTRY-LEVEL
WORKERS WERE ALL SEEING REAL
WAGE GAMES.
AVERAGE MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME
ROSE MORE THAN $6,000 AFTER
DECADES OF WAGE STAGNATION.
A FOCUS BY PRESIDENT TRUMP ON
THE AMERICAN WORKER, PROTECTING
AMERICAN MANUFACTURING, AND
HOLDING CHINA AND OTHER TRADE
SHEETS ACCOUNTABLE, THAT HELPED
HIM GROW HIS SUPPORT AMONG
WORKING-CLASS AMERICANS,
INCLUDING MORE LATINOS, BLACK
MEN, AND ASIAN-AMERICANS.
NOW, MOST PEOPLE DO NOT HAVE TO
LIKE HIS TWEETS TO LOVE HIS
RESULTS.
>> THE ECONOMY [INDISTINCT]
TO SUCCEED COME UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEY GOT TO THE
LOWEST EVER REPORTED IN U.S.
HISTORY.
>> Laura: BUT ALL OF THE GAINS
OUR WORKERS MADE ARE ABOUT TO BE
WIPED OUT IF BIDEN’S NEW
GLOBALIST COBOL HAS ITS WAY.
THEY ARE SHARPENING THEIR KNIVES
TO CUT WAGES AND SHIPPED JOBS
OFFSHORE.
THIS RAISES A QUESTION: WILL AOC
AND THE SQUAD STAND MUTE WHILE
AMERICAN WORKERS ARE CRUSHED
UNDER THIS AGENDA?
OR WILL THEY WORK WITH AMERICAN
POPULACE TO RESIST ANTIWORKER
POLICIES.
HERE ARE A FEW EXAMPLES OF WHERE
SHE COULD WORK WITH REPUBLICANS
TO BLOCK CORPORATIST DEMS.
NUMBER ONE, THE TRANS-PACIFIC
PARTNERSHIP.
BIDEN’S HANDLERS WANT HIM TO
JUMP BACK INTO THIS TRADE
AGREEMENT THAT TRUMPED NEXT.
WELL, TRUMP WAS RIGHT, IT IS A
JOB KILLER.
FOR THE PANDEMIC, WE HAD THE
STRONGEST ECONOMY IN THE G7 AND
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT.
AND WE STILL DO.
THE LAST THING WE NEED IS A JOB
KILLING TRADE DEAL.
NO MATTER WHAT BIDEN’S GURUS
CLAIMS, LEARNING LIVES OF WORKIN
PEOPLE HERE WILL NOT GIVE MORE
INFLUENCE IN ASIA.
IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT AND YOU
SOMEHOW THINK THE TPP WAS
A MISSED TRUMP OPPORTUNITY,
RECALL WHAT HILLARY CLINTON SAID
ABOUT IT IN 2016.
>> I WILL STOP ANY TRADE DEAL
THAT KILLS JOBS OR HOLDS DOWN
WAGES, INCLUDING THE
TRANS-PACIFIC PARTNERSHIP.
>> Laura: HILLARY KNEW THAT
WORKING-CLASS VOTERS DIDN’T WANT
THIS DEAL BECAUSE THEY KNEW IT
WOULD MEAN LOWER WAGES FOR THEM
AND FEWER JOBS AT HOME.
THERE IS A GREAT CHANCE FOR AOC
HERE, AND SHE SHOULD TAKE IT --
BY THE WAY, NATIONAL REVIEW IS
ALSO FOR THE TPP, THAT SHOULD
GIVE HER SOME THOUGHT.
NUMBER TWO, ENFORCE THE USMCA.
AOC VOTED AGAINST IT, WHICH
WAS AN UNFORTUNATE MISTAKE
BECAUSE OF CLIMATE ISSUES,
BECAUSE SHE COULD STILL INSIST
THE LABOR PROVISIONS COME AT THE
VERY LEAST, ARE HONORED.
SO WE FORCE MORE AUTO PRODUCTION
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES, GOOD
FOR AMERICAN WORKERS.
AND NUMBER THREE, CONTINUE TO
WEAKEN THE WORLD TRADE
ORGANIZATION.
OCASIO-CORTEZ COULD INSIST U.S.
TRADE POLICY BE MADE HERE, BY
AMERICANS AND FOR AMERICANS.
AFTER ALL, SHE IS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS, SO WHY WOULD SHE WANT
TO GIVE AWAY CONGRESSIONAL POWER
OVER TRADE?
SHE SHOULD END.
AND NUMBER FOUR, AOC COULD
INSIST THE NEXT U.S. TRADE REP
BE A POPULIST, NOT A
CORPORATIST.
HECK, I KNOW THIS SEEMS BIZARRE,
OR IT’S NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN,
BUT SHE MIGHT EVEN CONSIDER
INVITING TRUMP’S USTR INVESTOR
ROBERT LIGHTHIZER TO LUNCH.
HE’S BRILLIANT.
HE KNOWS ALL OF THE TRICKS OF
MULTINATIONAL CORPORATIONS, AND
I THINK THEY’D ACTUALLY BOTH
ENJOY THE EXCHANGE, NO HARM.
AND NUMBER FIVE, SHE COULD WORK
TO ACCELERATE EFFORTS TO
DECOUPLE FROM CHINA BOTH
ECONOMICALLY AND POLITICALLY.
HER CAUCUS MEMBERS TO SUPPORT
HUMAN RIGHTS, AND CHINA IS AMONG
THE WORST OFFENDERS IN THE WORLD
WORLD.
WHY SHOULD OUR FREE ECONOMY BE
OPEN TO THEIR WORKER ABUSING
COMPANY?
AND FINALLY, NUMBER SIX, SHE
COULD FORM A COALITION WITH KEY
CONSERVATIVES AND SOME DEMOCRATS
TO URGE THAT WE BRING OUR TROOPS
HOME, FINALLY, FROM THE
MIDDLE EAST.
IF PROGRESSIVES ARE TRULY
ANTIWAR, THEN THEY MUST NOT BE
SILENT, AS A BIPARTISAN
ESTABLISHMENT URGING THAT WE
STILL SEND TROOPS OVERSEAS AND
STOP TROOP WITHDRAWAL.
ALL SIX OF THESE STEPS WOULD BE
POPULAR WITH CONGRESSWOMAN
OCASIO-CORTEZ’S SUPPORTERS ON
THE LEFT.
SHE DOUBTS THAT COME ALL SHE HAS
TO DO IS TALK TO UNIONS LIKE THE
STEELWORKERS AND THE UAW, OR
YOUNG MILLENNIALS.
WHETHER THEY THINK WE SHOULD
STILL BE SENDING TROOPS TO
KANDAHAR.
I KNOW WHAT MANY OF YOU ARE
THINKING, THOUGH.
COME ON, LAURA, THIS IS ALL A
PIPE DREAM.
BUT I’M NOT SURE.
AOC HAS ALREADY SHOWN A
WILLINGNESS ON SOME ISSUES TO
WORK WITH CONSERVATIVES.
SHE AND TED CRUZ SIGNED A
LETTER -- THEY KIND OF SNIPE ON
TWITTER SOMETIMES, BUT THEY
SIGNED A LETTER CRITICIZING
APPLE FOR REMOVING A PRO
HONG KONG APP.
ALSO SLAMMED THE NBA FOR PUTTING
IN PROFITS FROM CHINA OVER
FREE SPEECH RIGHTS.
THEY ALSO WANT TO WORK TOGETHER
TO REIGN IN LOBBYISTS.
BULLOCK WHO BIDEN -- LOOK WHO IS
ON BIDEN’S TRANSITION TEAM.
ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," AT
LEAST 40 PEOPLE ON
PRESIDENT BIDENPRESIDENT-ELECT B
WERE LOBBYISTS.
THE ESTABLISHMENT USUALLY WINS
BECAUSE THE ESTABLISHMENT HAS
ENOUGH MONEY TO BUY OFF
CANDIDATES WITH CELEBRITY
STATUS.
DONALD TRUMP DID NOT GET THE
MAGAZINE COVERS, NEITHER DID THE
FIRST LADY, DESPITE HER GRACE
AND BEAUTY, BECAUSE NEITHER
AGREED TO PLAY BALL.
MOST PEOPLE AREN’T STRONG ENOUGH
TO RESIST THE TEMPTATION.
BUT THIS IS AN OLD TACTIC BY THE
ELITE.
REMEMBER BACK IN 1998?
HILLARY GOT GLAMOUR SHOTS IN
"VOGUE."
AND THEN, SHE WAS IN VOGUE IN
2007.
SUSAN RICE GOT HER SHOT IN 2013.
IT’S ALWAYS THE SAME.
PLAY BALL ON THE ECONOMIC
ISSUES, DON’T INTERFERE WITH
GLOBALIZATION, OR MAYBE EVEN
HELP OUT WITH OUTSOURCING, AND
WE’LL MAKE YOU A STAR.
WE’LL GIVE YOU THE CULTURAL
POWER TO BEAT UP ON
CONSERVATIVES, BUT WHEN IT COMES
TO MONEY IN FOREIGN POLICY, WE
EXPECT YOU TO GO ALONG WITH THE
GLOBAL ELITES.
SO, HILLARY AND HUMA AND SUSAN,
THEY ALL PROBABLY THOUGHT THEY
WERE HELPING THE WORKING PEOPLE,
TOO, BUT IN THE END, THE RICH
GOT RICHER AND CHINA GOT
STRONGER.
IN THE WORKING PEOPLE?
WELL, THEY TURNED TO
DONALD TRUMP.
SO, IT’S GOING TO BE INTERESTING
TO SEE AOC’S NEXT MOVE.
IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS, THE
ESTABLISHMENT HAS SHOWN HER THE
CARROT -- THE COVER OF
"VANITY FAIR," OF COURSE.
EMMA STICKS, LEAKS ABOUT HOW AOC
IS HURTING THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
SO IF SHE GOES ALONG ON THE
CHINA AND TRADE ISSUE AND HELPS
TECH BURROS GET RICHER, SHE WILL
HAVE A ONE-WAY TICKET WITH THE
IN CROWD.
AND IF SHE LEAVES POLITICS,
THEY’LL MAKE HER AN INSTANT
MULTIMILLIONAIRE.
BUT IF SHE STANDS UP TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT ON CHINA AND IF
SHE FIGHTS AGAINST THE TPP, IF
SHE TRIES TO END FOOLISH WARS,
WELL, THEN SHE’LL GET VERY
DIFFERENT TREATMENT.
WELL, THE CHOICE IS HERS, AND
SHALL HAVE TO MAKE IT SOON.
BY WORKING FOR POPULISTS, SHE
COULD REALLY HELP WORKING
PEOPLE.
AND FOR MANY FOLKS, THAT’S EVEN